everything has a process like with math
you learn the formulas and [ __ ] and then
you start to get results
because you can do every [ __ ] problem
if you know the formula you get what i'm
saying
you got a formula yeah yeah i got a
formula talk to them
my formula you give up the whole sauce
for real bro without the chefs though
that's what i'm saying you don't let
nobody interrupt your sauce when you
cooking
people have lost the understanding and
value of the word
you because at the end of the night you
gotta lay down
by yourself and get up in the morning
look yourself in the mirror
you got to be comfortable with all the
decisions that you make as a human and
stop depending on other people to supply
your happiness wants needs
thoughts and desires it's selfish but
it's real
and when you start believing in other
people that's how you open yourself
up to disappointments failures
heartbreak
depression all that [ __ ] cause your ex
your expectations is the fastest way to
disappointment
don't never let nobody or nothing
disappoint you you got to be comfortable
with yourself and know
that you are the key factor that can
change your situation your life
at the end of the day you are the
[ __ ] you are the key
y'all dj khaled is a major key yeah yeah
but you are the key
and every time you can put some
knowledge and work it and execute it
it's just like you got another one on
your on your loop of keys
the more keys you got the less you need
from other [ __ ]
if you're looking for somebody to make
you financially happy
and that's all you need you want
somebody because they got money or
whatever you think they can do for you
think of how you gonna feel when you in
that position and and you're not looking
for
nobody else to give you what you've been
craving
if money is your vice and you get some
money then what you're gonna have to
find another vice
because money ain't gonna be your it's
not gonna be a drug no more because
you're
in the excess of it and the thrill is
gone like the old blue song bb king the
thrill of it is gone
it's the thrill of the chase it's a lot
of [ __ ] that we think that we want until
we actually get it
so is that where you are right now like
you've gotten a lot of what you want
and it's not what you thought it would
be no it's not even that it's just that
that's why i can say that i'm happy with
where i am and
my success as a person or however people
may see it or not
i do what makes me happy you know what
i'm saying sometimes it's not a ferrari
that [ __ ]
that's your dream car your [ __ ] might be
right there in your grass it might be
the [ __ ] mustang that you wanted in
high school
or you know what i'm saying you always
just wanted the gt or some crazy [ __ ]
like whatever it is that you desire
see that's what separates the people
from like
like greatness and regular [ __ ]
desire the desire to be yourself
you know what i'm saying like you you
look i'm sitting here watching these
[ __ ] build his car you might
look at that [ __ ] and be like i don't
want that [ __ ]
but that's somebody's dream car that's
all they ever wanted you know what i'm
saying
yeah and so that's the type of [ __ ] i'm
saying it's like what is it that makes
you happy
it might not even be your iphone it
might just you guys got to live for
yourself it's basically what i'm saying
your happiness starts and ends with you
you being on the other side it's like
and just this being the follow-up
interview before you were
on the rise and you're still rising this
is by no means like
you're still almost you're just getting
started and where you're actually gonna
end up
but as you've seemed like you've seen
the other side of the fence now and
you've maybe
been in certain rooms with certain
people and you've seen the quote
important people right what it what is
that revealed to you
it's just what i finished saying all
that is what you learned yeah and that's
what i
remember you're happy it's like you're a
sitter you can be around
you can meet your idols man and they'll
sit there and you you'll see like damn
that's what make you connect with them
the realness you have to see somebody
you're like when somebody meets somebody
say damn you so down the earth
it's just a relatable cool dude
it's because they wasn't trying to
pretend to be the [ __ ] you
thought that they were yeah you know
what i'm saying those are the people who
are really the happiest man
and that's what i'm seeing a lot of
people missing out in the world you know
i'm saying a lot of people just
depressed
or just chasing [ __ ] that they think
that they're supposed to have to
make people like them and it's sad but
that's how you see a lot of people get
lost in the entertainment field they
start
chasing things items objects and people
you gotta have a vision though mm-hmm so
like how did you
develop your vision because you've made
trial and error i actually went through
and did it you know what i'm saying
none of the [ __ ] that i have or got in
my comedy career entertainment career
was handed to me i actually had to
physically put
labor into it so that's what made me
start seeing like okay [ __ ] if i do this
and this happens or this doesn't happen
then what
you know what i mean cause you still
gotta stay busy in between these
projects that [ __ ] don't come out when
you do it
you gotta stay hot until this [ __ ] come
on you don't wanna have the hottest tv
show on
on tv and you fell off in the six months
it took for them
you a waiter you got to quit your job so
you can go to your premiership
yeah yeah yeah i mean we we shot a tv
show together
a little while ago it was just like a
little pilot yeah and
it was dope too that was my first time
being around comedians of that caliber
where i'm like oh these are
like bro we're part of some classic [ __ ]
now bro we're working with
daniel rollins charlie charlie murphy
dude
and then it was like the mike ebbs
project though that yeah that's what it
was
that's what it was i'm saying man it's
just crazy how that happened
i never forgot about that and even even
the writers were dope these were dudes
who had written on like south park and
in living color like the whole project i
was like
yeah and then it's one of those things
that you know just never kind of well of
course not without charlie of course
right all right but i mean in general it
never really
being there and being a part of it i
know that that [ __ ] was funny as hell
so funny and it was it's probably still
could come out
hopefully one day somebody wants to see
it you have a lot of projects that you
shoot and then they just it just that's
just the game
yeah i think that's just part of the
game bro i mean it's it's people out
there who got
a hundred pilots or twenty or thirty you
know what i'm just saying
there's probably uh great shows that
they stopped production mid-episode like
nah this [ __ ] ain't gonna work
right just just because of the politics
of the game it's not always about the
the quality of the show the people who
run it it's it's people up top who just
sit back and they want to
they flip channels and they want to be
part of the wave of what's hiding new
right now they just
and they lose focus because they have a
boss
who doesn't give a [ __ ] about that they
just saw that this show is doing that
and that's right
that's what the network is doing yep
exactly it's [ __ ] up bro
a lot of talent get lost in that because
you know people
nobody likes rejection or feeling like
they fail
whether it be your fault or not so you
[ __ ] around and lose a job or
some [ __ ] you thought that you was gonna
you know some income that you was
expecting and you don't know how to
bounce back that [ __ ] can
cause depression and drugs and all types
of [ __ ] bruh
you been down that road yeah hell yeah
oh
i've lost a lot of money doing this here
talk about it
bro tell them i lost about 25 thousand
dollars for some cruises for some tweets
you just had some tweets they didn't
approve of yeah
what were they oh [ __ ] tweets wrestlers
tweeted
some [ __ ] like that i don't give a [ __ ]
man i don't nobody
run my [ __ ] and a lot of these promoters
and
people who booked you for shows they
think that that gives them access to
your social media where you're the
promoter
i got to be the promoter and the talent
[ __ ] you i'm not doing that [ __ ] unless
that's part of the pay like right
hang on [ __ ] i'm gonna post this [ __ ] to
let the people know they're following me
to come [ __ ] with me but i'm not about
to
promote this [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you talking about you the
headliner were you the promoter
your name says promoter you're right
they're not
coming they they're coming because you
told them i was coming
it's not to see a lot of times you go do
shows in these cities and they go out
and [ __ ] didn't settle out it's not that
they don't [ __ ] with me they don't [ __ ]
with you
i'm coming to do a show in your city
where you live
you don't and you're a promoter and you
don't know 300 people how you a promoter
then
you can't bring 200 people to a club 300
people
you the promoter half of the club
supposed to be your people
promoter mm-hmm the other the other half
is
you supposed to be no we can't have to
add another show because
because i promoted this [ __ ] well man
you ain't dead [ __ ]
this is the game is ugly man hey hot
brother and sister
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more
comedy tips